the boot camp and we'll have the
pleasure of listening to Susana and the
reason they will talk about start
talking about proofs circuits and total
search programs
okay so yeah just please feel free to
interrupt that any moment
um
and tell me if I'm going too fast or too
slow
okay so uh one of the motivations I
could say to talk about this this topic
is that there have been many papers
coming out lately I even didn't update
this with the ones uh this last year
which really have these total search
problems at the center
and and there are some new connect new
connections between uh these two
different worlds and they're actually
new but extending like classical ones uh
so both
um so viewing uh proof and query
complexity as one of the worlds and
circuit and communication complexity as
the other
um and the
um newer uh connection would be in uh
one of these directions even though it
dates back
so
um and all and this is like part of a
bigger Theory which I will touch upon at
the end but I will mostly uh stick to
more classical uh relations during the
talk
So the plan is as follows we'll uh I'll
try to introduce these two
um yeah more classical connections and
at least to give some intuition of uh
where they come from so the yeah tree
like resolution and decision trees
monotone Boolean formulas and
communication protocols uh and then try
to explain the where these total search
problems come why are they Central
and then uh explain how these two worlds
are connected which we already saw a
feasible interpolation in Tony's talk
um and then lifting theorems which go in
the other direction
uh and then finally I'll end up with
some so just some recent results that
have used this point of view uh and some
open problems
so oh and there's more on this uh uh
there's a complexity guess column which
is kind of a short high level
um survey on some of the things I'll
touch upon
uh uh Robert has a talk online which
um also has a lot of this and there are
many recent papers on tfnp which I
recommend
okay so uh tree-like resolution and
decision trees uh so the here are the
the total search problem we'll be
focusing on is this we um Tony already
mentioned this falsified class search
problem uh so here we're given an
unsatisfiable CNF formula
um here I have M Clauses and and the
goal is to find some uh clause which is
falsify by the given assignments so it's
it's total because it's unset right
and and I'll just view this as a
relation
um and I have a x here and a kind of
overloading notation for the variables
and assignments but I would say a pair
XI is in this relation if the assignment
X falsifies close I
um and this is exactly the search
Problem
okay uh in general total search problems
uh are the they have some input and some
outputs for now we can think of the
input as just 0 1 to the end
and
um and I'll write uh so s of X is all
the possible feasible outputs given the
the input X
and it's total if for all x uh in the
input there there is at least one
possible
um feasible output
and uh yeah as I mentioned this is this
uh the search app is a total search
problem if F isn't set if and only if
that doesn't set
okay so this is what we would like to
compare the query complexity of this
problem with the proof complexity of
refuting app
okay
uh okay so we already saw resolution
proofs
um so just to mention that'll be uh
considering for now tree like resolution
proofs uh I'll use a rough estimate for
PSI so it's just a number of nodes in
the tag I won't really look at the size
of each clause
um and I'll be talking
yes I will next slide I will
um and yeah I'll use the notion of depth
of the proof the longest uh path from us
the source to the sink and uh the notion
of width which is the maximum number of
literals in any Clause appearing in the
proof so these are the measures are you
I'll use
okay so query complexity
so uh here we have a decision tree that
is solving this this falsified class
search Problem
so it uh the query complexity will just
be the depth of this tree
so it's querying variables and at the
end it has to Output a falsified costs
so
the classical result here is that a
tree-like resolution
refutation of a Formula F is equivalent
to the decision tree complexity of the
falsified Clause search Problem
okay so here uh we can we have two
examples which actually look very much
alike but let's see let's see why uh
these are essentially the same object
so first
um yeah I'll do Just One Direction but
suppose we're given
a tree-like resolution refutation and
now we have to come up with
a decision tree that solves the
falsified class search Problem
so uh we'll
uh what we'll do is we'll look at what
is the variable I'm resolving on at each
step
um that will be the very variable I'm
query
and the invariant I'll keep is that the
assignment so far is going to falsify
the corresponding Clause so at the
beginning I have the empty assignments
and it falsifies the empty Clause so I'm
fine
um the first variable that I resolving
on in this case a text one so that's
going to be the variable I query
and and now I have to consider with
what's true then X1 being true falsifies
the Clause not X1 so I'm keeping the the
invariance and now I look at what is the
next uh variable I resolve on and well
that's X2 and now I'll consider true and
false uh according to what falsifies the
the Clauses there so again I'm keeping
the invariance and so on
so as you can see
um I get exactly the same structure so
not only is it the case that yeah size s
that the tree like resolution reputation
implies suggests that the decision tree
but I actually get a same structure and
also in in the other direction I can
also you can also do this
okay
any questions here
so now
um uh right so what is the query
complexity of a total search problem so
now this would correspond to what is
polynomial time
um so we have the the total search
problem and uh so the query complexity
of it would be the depth of the
shallowest decision tree that solves
um this problem
and I'll I'll call uh this fpdt uh all
the total search problems that can be
solved with depth poly login
okay so this is what corresponds to the
polynomial time in in the total search
problems
um so let's see some examples for
example uh if I have
um the the problem I had given the graph
which is not too colorable
and the problem is to find some and then
give a give a coloring of it and the
question is can I find a monochromatic
edge of G
so this this problem is in uh in this
class and why well if it's the graph is
not too colorable it has some odd cycle
I can just do a binary search in the out
cycle and find a
uh Edge which is monochromatic
another example would be unsaturated to
CNF formula uh there's a similar
argument where I find a cycle and do a
binary search
so these are some problems that are in
in
um
fpdt
okay so what is the NP correspondence
here
um so uh so here we have we'll Define
the notion of certificates so a
certificate is just a partial assignment
and uh such that there is some some
output
for which all assignments that are
consistent with this partial assignment
has have this output as a possible
answer
so
um so this would be a possible
certificate and I would like a set of
certificates that actually covers all
inputs so that there there is one
certificate in in the class that is uh
consistent with uh so for every X there
exists once one certificate which is
consistent with it
and once I have a certificate cover of
us then I can come up with an NP
algorithm that uh solves this search
problem and it's it's simply well I just
guess the certificate and now I just
need to query uh in my input just what
my certificate what are the the
variables that it fixes
so I query that and check whether X is
consistent with that
so the the complexity of this uh NP
algorithm would be the maximum size of
any uh of the number of fixed
coordinates on in any uh certificate in
my certificate cover so this will be the
notion of complexity here for this
algorithm
foreign
so now I can also Define similarly so
this class tfnp DT of s would just be
the minimum over all certificate covers
of this measure
and uh and then and and this whole class
tip in pvt would be all all total search
problems that have a measure of poly
login
foreign
does this make sense
okay so what are you trying to Define
this corresponding
this this is supposed to be uh the NP
version for total search problems
um so I'm trying to yeah Define what are
what would be a certificate and I would
like to cover all possible inputs since
it's a total search problem there should
be a certificate for all inputs
but what was the DT is supposed to be oh
the DTs decision tree sorry yes
yes because I'm talking about this so
here in this model I'm Aquarium
uh the number of queries
would be the depth of the decision sheet
so there's a non-deterministic part
where I guess
but then I query
um the part of my certificate that's
fixed
and check query MX those positions and
check that it's consistent with my
certificate
next one like all all CNF formulas of
the most poly logarithmic
with their like NP easy because it just
it just gets a falsified clause and
check that it's falsified but the
deterministic like position
way larger
yeah exactly
yes yes
it's a real president
is
here
you would just choose a certificate
yeah
exactly so yeah you there exists uh
forever but there existed there's
certain trees so if it would get that
one
foreign
so if we have an unsatisfiable CNF
formula the Clauses are a certificate
cover for the falsified Cloud search
problem so
I know that the complexity the TF and
PDT complexity of search at is
um
not more than the width of this formula
okay
the sorry the number of uh uh literals
in the maximum number of letters and any
clouds appearing in the formula yeah
so that that's exactly what I would have
to query to make sure that my assignment
falsifies the class
um and the reason this this problem
falsified Clause search problem is so
important is that it's it is complete in
some sense because if I have so suppose
I have any any search problem s and uh
consider well any certificate cover
maybe the best one possible
then I can reduce it to some search f
for some formula f
and the formula I choose is simply I
look I look at all the certificates in
in the certificate cover and I Define
the Clause that is exactly falsified by
the this certificate
so it's the maximum with Clause
falsified by
the certificate
um and and now if I solve the search
problem for this formula uh and I find a
falsified Clause I will be buying
finding a certificate uh in R for uh the
assignment and also conversely if I find
the certificate in R then I can find a
um a falsified clause
so it is complete in this sense
okay so we have a similar uh parallel in
the monotone circuit and communication
uh protocols world
so you'll kind of see the same structure
I'll go over again but now in this world
okay so uh I think I'll go over this but
I think most most of you have to know
this very well there uh so uh we have
the customer Victor Sim game so we have
a Boolean function f here it can be a
partial Boolean function
um and I'll def so there's a total
search problem which is the customer
customer big distance game on F I'm
given uh in uh X in the pre-image of one
y and primage of zero so these inputs
have to be different and the goal is to
find some index where they differ
um and this is a total search problem
now my input is actually not just zero
one to the N but it's uh uh this cross
product
and and so let's just see some examples
so with f is parity and I have these two
inputs then the only uh possible output
I can give is four it's the only place
where they differ
um and uh here I have
two inputs that differ in uh three
positions so yeah there are three
possible answers here
okay
um so uh we have this this notion of the
customer victorson game and there's a
monotone version of it so if f is
monotone then uh the monotone customer
break this game of f is actually a
harder problem because I'm I'm asked to
find an i where
um uh x i is 1 and y i is zero
and since its monotone this has to Exist
by the definition of monotonicity
um so let's go back to this example from
majority uh so here the this possibility
here with x y 3 would not be
um an answer for the monotone version
even though it's an answer for the
non-monitable version so this is the
strictly harder problem
and now
um what customer Victorian showed was
that the communication complexity which
I'll Define now of this customer's
customer big distance game of that is
exactly the circuit complexity
um of F and also in the monotone world
so
um so this is just to say I'll be
considering um de Morgan Boolean
circuits so I just have Oren and Gates
and uh I have variables or
negated variables as inputs
um and yeah I'll just be considering
yes
don't you need a log of them
um yeah so I'll Define what this
complexities mean uh so in order it will
be depth in both cases
or yeah what I'll talk about now is the
depth in both cases
yeah but there's also a similar for size
in both cases
um okay so the communication protocol uh
so we have these two players Alice and
Bob
um Alice has the input and the pre-image
of one bomb in the pre-image of zero and
their goal is to find an index where
their inputs differ
uh and their communication protocol is
this uh strategy tree it defines who
speaks
and uh and at the end they should output
what is which uh of their
um what what is the index of their bits
that differ
yeah and and these are the two
complexity measures I'll talk about here
too
so this probably looks familiar uh so
let's see how from uh now a formula uh I
can get a communication protocol that
solves the customer Victorian game
um okay so uh I have and and or Gates
so what I'll do is uh every end gate
will be Bob that speaks uh every or gate
is Alice and then variants will keep is
that uh if we consider the partial
function computed at a given gate
uh Bob's inputs will be in the pre-image
of zero of that gate uh Alice's infant
will be in the pre-image of one of that
gate as they walk down the tree
so this is true at the beginning because
we're guaranteed that that's the input
that they get
and now we just have to make sure that
they can follow
um this until the end because then uh
the end is just is just
um uh literal so then
they'll have a different function
and if it's monotone Bob will have a
zero and Alice will have a one which is
exactly what they have to fight
okay so
um uh Bob starts uh he'll start speaking
and he has to say which direction to go
um and those and the or Gates Alice will
speak and she will say what direction
she has to go so let's consider uh an
input so Alice has suppose she has one
zero zero Bob has uh zero one zero and
now
uh just to make sure that Alice has
something in the pre-image of one if we
compute this formula here we'll see that
uh Alice gets a one and if we compute it
for Bob you can see that Bob gets a zero
okay so this is a valid input
and now let's see what Alice what uh
yeah Bob and Alice would do so uh Bob
since he gets a zero he has to go to the
gates where he's still His function is
still zero so what he'll do if he had
this input would say well I have to go
to this gate
and then now once here Alice has a one
she has to have a one because that was
an ant so she has to have one in both
directions
um and now she can say since this is an
or gate she can say which of these two
uh she has a one she has to have one in
at least one and Bob has to have zero on
both so that would be a valid one
that makes sense
okay and similarly as we
um
had before the converse also
also holds
so this again is really uh you really
get the same object the graph structure
is the same when we do this
this translation
so in the communication complexity world
we also have these uh total search
problems and now the designing fpcc
because we're in the communication World
um and the complexity will be the depth
of the shallowest protocol
uh that solves the total search problem
and we have the input divided between
the two players
um and again the
uh polynomial time version of this will
just be all search problems that have
uh communication protocol trees of uh
depth poly login
and now the NP
um communication complexity of these
total search problems again will have
certificates but now the certificates
they look like rectangles
of some subset of alices and plus a
subset of Bob's input
um such that there is some answer which
is called which is common to all inputs
in here
okay so this this uh this is a a
certificate and again we want uh
uh set of certificates that cover all
inputs so it looks something like like
this it's a set of rectangles that cover
all inputs
so given this we can again Define our NP
algorithm
which uh solves the search problem so
now Alice is getting some X Bob is
getting some Y and now they both have to
non-determine non-deterministically
guess uh what rectangle they're in uh
they can end up in the independently
check that they're actually in in that
rectangle but now they have to
communicate uh log number of rectangles
uh bits to make sure that they both have
the same rectangle
so the complexity uh of solving some
search problem with I would look at the
smallest possible
um rectangle cover of s and
um and that would be the log of the
number of rectangles
and again the
um the tfnp class would consist of all
the total search problems that have that
have complexity poly login yes so when
you define the collects me as a depth of
the shot shell is probably just about a
number of bits set right number of bit
sets yes because I thought it rounds but
then it's always one you just send the
input to the other person yeah yeah no
it's it's number of bits and so I'm just
viewing the tree and considering the
depth of the thing
um and the reason for this is uh we'll
get to it soon because you can also
consider size
so that's what I'll
um I'll get to soon
is there a reason why you're considering
poly login as opposed to just like oh
vlogging or something
yeah that's a that's a good question
like um I I'd say the reason it's Unique
you need at least login so that's that
would be uh just because you have any
possible answers for
um most of these settings so you need
and your tree has to have at least that
login
um and so yeah the natural measure that
comes out is this
um
I don't know maybe Robert has a better
answer okay
well anything can be done in complexity
n so if that's the analogy of like
exponential time like two to the end
like if we're taking a palette like
everything is scaled down by a logarithm
so like poly log is kind of the more
natural width think of it as an oracle
so like the strings that they have on
like oracles and so the input sizes
login
okay okay
because sometimes when they get describe
tsmp they uh they actually have this
tailing so the input is actually of
exponential size and then they say yeah
this makes sense yeah
um okay and again now uh we also have
some sort of conflictness of this uh of
the monotone awkward
um so first given some uh function f we
have this natural rectangle cover which
is simply I just look at all the bits of
my inputs and whenever uh they uh I I
look at all X's such that x i equals one
or why such that y i equals zero and
that will give me one rectangle and I do
this for all I so I'll have a total of n
rectangles and that covers all
uh all my input so this is a this would
be a rectangle cover for the monotone KW
game of that so I I do have that this
complexity is
um bounded by log n
and and the completeness comes uh from
the fact that so if I have any rectangle
cover
um I can reduce this to some monotone KW
game for some function f
um so I'll try to to sketch this here so
I will Define the function
so I'm given these rectangles and I have
to Define this function and I'll Define
it by it's going to be a partial
function by defining the pre-image of
one in the pre-image of zero
okay
um so for this I'll consider
um the
all possible inputs for Alice of the
problem or possible use
and uh so I will look at a u and
consider all the rectangles that this U
crosses when I vary the possible Bob
inputs so in this case it it's Crossing
R1 and R2 but not R3 and R4 for this U
so that would give me a string of 1 1 0
0.
so that this is what this um function
um
forgot what I want to call this
it's uh indicator
for rectangles for you okay
um and I'll do something similar for the
v's but I'll look at the opposite of the
indicator
so now whenever it crosses so here it's
Crossing all of them except for R2
so now I will have a one only in the
second position
it has a zero and all the rectangles it
crosses
and you can sort of tell uh what I'm
getting at because exactly where they
coincide that that rectangle is where
um Alice has a one and Bob has to have a
zero and all the rectangles that oh well
in this rectangle yeah where they
coincide so first let's argue that okay
yeah so
um the the pre-image of one will be for
I will just look at all use and just
look at all the strings I can get
and pre-image of zero I will look at all
these
and all the strings I get by the
um uh non-indicator vector
so first yeah we have to argue that this
is well defined that this is actually
the uh a function a partial function
um so
for any
uh UV
I there is some rectangle since this is
a total function there is some rectangle
where they uh they're both in and this
corresponds exactly to some input where
Alice has a one Bob has a zero
so they cannot be they cannot be giving
the same string so this is a
well-defined function
and then from here we can also see that
uh if if our one is a possible uh answer
then bit one will also be a possible
answer and vice versa if if uh
um this bit one where they differ
is a possible answer that means that uh
Alice is in rectangle one and Bob is in
rectangle one because that's how we
Define
this can be a little bit tricky and I'm
not sure I explained it uh so well so
please ask if it's not clear
okay
okay so that in this sense the monotone
version is the is the one that is
um complete we cannot we can't do the
same thing for the non-monitone version
so we need this it's harder so it's
easier to reduce things to it
so yeah what I've tried to do making the
slides also similar is to show that
there's really like a strong parallel
between these these two worlds so on on
one side we had these basic like uh
um objects which was these unsatisfiable
CNF formulas we defined the total search
problem
um and then we saw that yeah the
tree-like resolution refutation was
equivalent to the decision tree of these
total search problems and on on the
other side we have this uh non-tom
Boolean functions we have also a total
search problem and then we have this
equivalent between monotone Boolean
formulas and communication protocols for
the monotone kwk
um and we can also continue doing this
um uh parallel so these these formulas
they are uh bottom up way of viewing uh
the object we're starting from the
variables and building up the formula
and the communication Protocols are a
top down right now let's Barber
communicating and the same thing here we
have a refutation is this bottom up from
axioms I have to derive contradiction
and the decision tree is a top-down View
and
uh and then here we have um Clauses on
for reputations that's the objects in
each node and this for the decision tree
we have partial assignments
um and then we have these yeah detection
rules or versus uh querying variables
and here we have for the circuit
intermediate functions and for the
protocols we have these rectangles
um we have the gates versus the
communication communicated bits and we
have these both canonical search
problems so there's a real like parallel
we can see between both worlds
foreign
except for this yeah
um yes and then uh in both settings we
can also view have a tag like version so
this is just normal resolution
um and the decision tag
um I I won't really Define it but you
can just you can think of I can merge
parts of the tree which I would actually
look the same that's the idea
um so I can get something smaller
um yeah because I don't I don't have to
repeat and then here I can also consider
circuits and there's also a same kind of
merging idea that can be done for
communication protocols which create
something that we're called rectangle
decks
um and and we have the same kind of a
relation with regards to size here size
of size
foreign
yeah I'd like to talk about how these
two worlds relate so this interpolation
and lifting
are there any questions
okay so
um yeah how can I turn a
falsify cross search problem into a
monotone KW game
um
well I I need the game I need I have two
players so I need to somehow partition
the variables
of of my search problem into uh two sets
so I have my original variables I can
simply I don't know in some way
partition it between Alice involved like
if some variable style is some to Bob
uh and it's not hard to see that if I
have an efficient decision tree for this
problem then I can easily get an
efficient communication protocol for the
same the same problem but now with the
variables partitions so whenever the
decision query the decision tree queries
some of the original variable z i
Whoever has that variable will simply
tell the other player what the variable
is and they can just simulate the
decision tree
what's up
search if not correspond aw the search
should be F which is monitoring itself
now in some sense for the search
so here I haven't gone into the monoton
PW game the how that will come in is
because it's canonical
here I'm getting the sum so that's my
this point here so I'm getting to some
total search Problem
um and now I want to get to a monotone
KW game and I will use exactly the fact
that it's complete so that's that's what
allows me to actually get and if it if
we just had KW game I can't guarantee
that there's there would be such a
translation
so let's see what how this translation
works
this is exactly where uh interpolation
comes in
um so this was yeah something already
appearing in
um this is raspber of 90 but also that
the puzzles
um
uh having a more recent paper of 2017
um and and what they showed is that the
this
for any partition uh X Y of the
variables this search Problem
with this partition variables is exactly
equivalent to the monotone KW game for
this function here
okay so before I uh get to this function
let me go back to something that Tony
um talked about when she talked about
interpolation she talked about these
split formulas right so we have a
formula that has some common variables
that and part of the formula is saying
that X that Z is encoding a graph that
has a k click and the other part is
saying that Z is encoding the graph that
is K minus one colorable
um and what the function that you get
here would be the click coloring
function so it receives as input this
graph it outputs one if that has a k
click uh zero if uh that is K minus one
colorable and it cannot put anything if
none are the case
um and this is exactly what you uh which
you can get by doing the correct
partition of of the variables here so
the idea is that the Z will Define
um
yeah I sorry I didn't write this here so
every class CI uh this Ciy is the part
of CI that contains only the variables
given to Bob and cyx is the part of the
Clause that contains only the variables
given to Alice
and the z i is defining uh into which
set I would like these um the CI to go
to
if they were uh if they were both
satisfiable that would mean I would have
a satisfying assignment for the whole
formula
because uh yeah I would be satisfying
all the positions whereas at I equals
zero all the Clauses were said I equals
zero by the X variables and now the
um uh Clauses where is that I equals one
by the Y variables so it can't be there
they're both satisfiable
and uh and here the goal is to actually
determine which one
um which one is not satisfiable
original
interpolation of those
things
so it was it was not actually described
that search reduces to monotone it was a
specific search for specific air that
has
so he
um
they translated each proof line into a
wonderful communication and then it
translates
to get back into a monarchy circuit
bring something more generous um yeah so
this this is just translating the
problems themselves this is not saying
whether the proof system
gets so what they show is that given a
resolution reputation I can get a
monotone Circuit by translating each
step
right uh this I'm not doing here here
I'm only talking about the problems that
they're solving it's a reduction between
problems
um so I guess the corresponding here
would be that if I could inter uh if I
could compute this function I would be
interpolating this circuit
interpolating this this formula
so it's just the relation between the
problems
um
where does the
supposedly modern change between let's
see the translation into just monoton
when you you've shown that uh for any
action it's it's going to be
translatable into monotone lower parts
it's fine
for any Formula F I can it's equivalent
to the amount of the of this function
here yes
um
yeah the original ones it had to be like
the split kind of formula right
that's that's the difference is that
yeah here it had to be formulas that
could that had these common variables
and
this is giving you uh monitor
interpolation
uh it's yeah maybe I should have said
that I'm sorry uh so if I put any bit of
Zed from zero to one
that means I'm moving some pauses from
here
to here
uh so that means that uh the function
can only change from one to zero so yeah
this is this is a monotone function yeah
sorry I should
yeah and I was going to mention that uh
so what's
um yeah cry check and then also putlock
uh showed was that if but by using no
there's no monotone circuit lower Bound
for uh this coloring function I would
get a lower Bound for uh resolution and
then for cutting planes uh for this
formula here
so this this was uh their result
um and
uh and using this more General
um translation
um in two independent uh papers they
showed that you can get lower lower
bounds for cutting planes for these
random uh log and cnfs
this these are not these kind of split
formulas so you couldn't get it via this
um yeah this view of interpolation
um questions
correct and so so what uh what do we
have like summarizing so if we have a
decision tree for the search problem F
then uh we have a communication protocol
for this the search problem with the
partition variable and that is
equivalent to the monotone KW game of
this function
so given a a small decision tree or a
small depth decision tree I get a a
small depth communication protocol for
this problem
um and I can view this in terms of lower
bound which is usually how
um oh for sorry the I wrote here in
terms of proof and circuits
um and I could view this in terms of
lower bound uh proving a lower bound
here gives me a lower bound here
um and now I guess uh the question is we
said there's these two relations so what
about the converse right so we saw
um upper bounds for search F gives upper
Bound for it's monotone KW game and it's
not true that the other direction is
always
always holds but is it the case that at
least for some formulas the converse is
also is also true
and and this is exactly what we get from
lifting so if if this formula is a
lifted formula for a right Gadget then
this is true by lifted what I mean so a
gadget is just uh
um function which has a partition's
input
and I will just compose
my original
formula with n copies of this gadget one
for each input so this gives a natural
partition of the variables
um of the of the original function by by
what I have in the gadget and
and I yeah simply give all of one one of
the sides to Alice and the other side uh
to Bob
so for the right gadgets this function
uh that I get by composing will uh the
converse will also hold
and this right Gadget uh is there are
other gadgets that work depending on the
lifting theorem but the
um
uh Mo most General Gadget is this
indexing Gadget which is simply I have a
I have a string y of length L and I have
a pointer to somewhere in that string
and the indexing is simply I'll just
look at the the X position in the
y-strick and that's my function
uh and this is what the the lifting
theorem says it's exactly the other
direction so if I have a size s that say
communication protocol for that same
function then I get a poly s uh death of
the decision tree for
for
um this composed function
um and this is uh yeah has been used to
prove uh lower bounds
okay and it's it's some it somehow
um yeah I feel like it's nicer because
it's it's uh easier to prove lower
bounds for decision trees than it is for
communication protocols so in some sense
I'm transferring uh the hard problem of
proving a communication protocol or
circuit lower bound to an easier problem
of considering decision trees
okay so uh so yeah so this is this is
the relation we saw for interpolation
um this is the corresponding relation
for lifting in the other direction which
uh here I just
um uh wrote it in terms of the lower
bounds that we uh usually use so it's a
deputy decision tree lower bound would
give a size n to the D communication
protocol
um and again here I've been talking
about trees but this also works for for
Dax so
um yeah I can have rectangle tags and
decision tags
um and then the difference is that
instead of depth I use the notion of
width that's the difference in the dag
world
um yeah so just to mention we said firm
interpolation we were able to get from
monotone circuit lower bounds lower
bounds improve complexity and from this
lifting we can get from a resolution
with lower belt for example for
pigeonhole principle we can get a
monotones which is something
um I guess easy to prove we can get uh
just Black Box by using this a monotone
circuit lower Bound for the click
coloring function
so it's yeah a block it gives you a
black box way of uh getting monotone
circuit lower bounds for some functions
yeah yes they're more General like to
other gadgets functions work is there
sort of a general more General if there
are is there are more General
characterizations with properties that
you need to make such a theorem go
through so yeah but uh you can use other
other functions so there's other
other circular bonds you can use by just
saying Gadget indexing you can get other
lower bounds
um with regards to other gadgets uh
there are there are some more General
lifting theorems but
for the tree-like case
for the dog like
um the only I think the only Gadget
um that I know of
is by mixing gadgets for which you could
just
search
school there's no proof systems oh um
it's just resolution and money
so this will correspond to a resolution
with
that and here is the first one
and then just yeah just to mention some
uh some of the recent results that came
from these uh lifting theorems so uh one
of them was uh two to the end lower
Bound for some monotone formulas
um Computing some function nnp so this
is not yeah this is
function in monotone P there's almost
the optimal lower belt and these were
approved using lifting
um also there was some separation proved
in
um yeah the monotone found the depth
world and also between monotone circuits
and
um Mountain C2
or nc2 sorry
not monitored
um and then and then also this this
result yeah uh lower bounds for uh
cutting panes and monotone circuits from
uh this with lower Bound for resolution
so this is using yeah the dag-like
lifting theorem and yeah and this was
the only way we knew of proven cutting
planes lower bound was the interpolation
so this gave like another another way of
proving cutting planes lower bounds
um and and this was this
um generalized interpolation that gave
this uh login random login uh lower
bounds for cutting planes
there have been some also size based
trade-offs for different proof systems
also using lifting
um and there are even some results which
are not directly related to
uh proof circuit complexity so I this is
what I I particularly like it's very
combinatorial and it's and it uses also
uh this Machinery to
foreign
okay
so yeah just to sum up so this is part
of a more uh General framework so you
can't see this very well but uh we
talked about the tree-like systems this
tree-like relations here dagger like uh
relations would correspond to PLS but
there are other subclasses of tfnp which
also have corresponding proof systems
some of which uh we also have a
corresponding circuit model but not for
all of them
um and yeah uh one interesting problem
um that I've yeah heard someone mention
here but is I can is there a gen so we
have this generalized picture which we
can view for decision trees and for
communication complexity and for some of
these we have lifting theorems relating
the decision tree and the communication
uh World
um can we prove a generalized like from
any class decision tree to any class
communication to the same class
communication
um if so we could get lower bounds for
communication classes which we don't
know because we only know the lower
bounds for the query analog
um so if there were such lifting
theorems we could
um yeah get lower bounds
um and then there yeah I think there are
many interesting questions regarding
these lifting theorems
um what is their relation with other
other lower bound techniques
uh what can improve what can it not
prove
um and then there yeah I think many
questions I guess in proof and circuit
complexity of things that seem simple
enough but we don't know how to do and
can we also understand like why uh why
is this hard why why can't we prove uh
exponential size lower Bound for
um monotone circuits for matching is
there uh so one one thing is we imagine
it does not seem to be a lifted type of
uh function so it seems like you can't
prove uh any definitely any an
exponential lower bound using lifting
but can we understand like yeah can we
give a good excuse why why we haven't
been able to prove this yet
information uh it's quasi polynomial
it has a linear depth lower bound but
thank you
[Applause]
what questions for Susana
verification for uh
matched precisely with the the monotone
such problems of projections
same because for this right and I I
said to follow when it's going to be
used and get some results
just the reduction to the from instead
of split formulas to uh
like when when is interpolation
well what was the the precise
formalization of the lift games
experience
foreign
[Music]
function
there were 12 and uh
Define the set problem and you can
Define the function for the right
so it will apply to some function
and it was a specific one
[Music]
section
[Music]
one from the mono concept
a couple of slides before
yeah or no before this
foreign
research problem
s
and then from from here we can we can
show its equivalence to some uh
or some function to the monotone kwc
into that condition
okay
friends
so you mentioned the resolution
authorities you have the same connection
with 30 decision trees like you have for
resolution
um you have the same connection to
parody decision trees for for the
three-line version yeah
yes yes
then you would have to Define uh yeah I
think yeah you can define a deadlike
version of yes
can I say something about what makes
index a good gadget for lifting ah okay
first it's Universal so any any Gadget
that you have you can simply on the on
the Bob side just write out all possible
outputs you would get and then Alice
simply points to so it's the hardest
possible Gap gadgets right so that's
also makes it through large and yeah and
Bob's side it is too large that's true
but uh usually it's enough to have one
small size
side so because Alice can can simply
send her pointer and Bob doesn't have to
send anything except one bit so even
though he has a larger
yeah it's okay but it would be
interesting to get something like more
balanced and smaller cabinets here
so let me just was that a question
so we'll be back at 3 30.